in real life you do see a lot of as
steven said even i'm i'm actually
you know an example of this so i know
that
women are believed
but um
in terms of the situation it i am
surprised as to i wonder why they didn't
because there might be just other
reasons as to what he may have been
saying and as i said they must have been
a tussle but generally speaking
as it's it's been seen women are more
believed than men you know see the
situation i wasn't in the room in his
interview i don't know what his
interview said i don't know what he was
asking i have no idea but what i do know
is
that
um
he knew he could get away with it
and that is exactly what happened he
also did other things after the fact
that they also completely ignored
someone sitting outside your house for
two years
and then them not checking the cctv i
think anyway in the uk the police force
let me not even them not even go there
but um
in terms of like women being believed i
feel like
in the reality especially in this
country there are women that have had
evidence
and have spoken up
and they are not listened to to the
point where it becomes
detrimental there are women that have
actually passed away because of not
being listened to so it's not about not
being believed they're believed but it's
kind of like
oh there's not much we can do about it
there's not much we can do about it
until it becomes really really bad well
just you know what that is i couldn't
even answer that but i think if we look
at cases that's just in general across
the board i think it just depends on the
police the police force the police the
area you live
i just say where you are in the state
it's like on a status level so it just
all depends because unfortunately we
hear that all the time you hear every
day in the news like you could hear
someone talking about oh they knew that
was a suicide bomber they'd come to the
house it'd be reports social service
even an example saying someone's been
doing whatever to children whatever it
is
you always find that there's people that
negligent on in terms of their
professional
professionalism and that's actually what
just happens he says unfortunately you
might just get a or i might
get a bad bad unprofessional person and
i think that's just unfortunate how it
is
did you know in most domestic violence
cases both parties are abusing each
other
and in one-sided abuse cases um
the
woman actually abuses the man like one
side of meaning it's not retaliated
the woman abuses the man 70 percent of
the time
absolutely and i think there's a
misconception that women are weak
when it comes to domestic violence i
feel that
you know people assume the man stronger
he could have done this he could have
done that and then when you look at the
acts of violence against men it's more
not to say more malicious but the
tactics used are more manipulative and
they can have impact on the man that
maybe he won't talk about it for a long
time
do you get what i mean so when we're
talking about domestic violence against
men
it's a different kettle of fish in the
way they're being abused
i feel like with women they can say oh
he hit me or he punched me and people
take action
where is he so
when it comes to abusive i was just
looking because i've got a website
for um it's called domestic abuse
the national center for domestic abuse
is talking about male domestic abuse and
it says
the organization reports that 95 of its
callers suffer emotional abuse these are
men
right so men suffer 95 emotional abuse
68 is physical
41 is psychological 23 is financial
13 is coercive control and 3
is sexual abuse
towards men
like when men suffer from domestic
violence
i can believe that emotional abuse for
men
it
they don't talk about their emotions in
general and i think that when men say
they're being emotionally abused what
what is the line where do what do we
look at
i think what it is is that even
interesting
just being on this podcast
and as a man you automatically know that
it's not something you're meant to talk
about
where women are because of being
emotionally they're allowed to speak on
it so i already know
that you you if you can picture the
comments
you know as men know that if you go and
speak about these things
it's actually like these words like simp
and look at this one like we talking
about blah blah so that's why it's like
man up and you know to some degree i get
it
but the thing is something you said
which is important just now is that
someone i wish there was there's a word
there's a term i need to find it but
it's actually where that's used it's
very manipulative where because it was
happened to me i was i was actually
personally told no one would believe you
but that that thing where because you're
the strong or you're the physical
it's that that's the license that you
can hit me attack me say whatever you
say to me because we're the physically
stronger and even true to social service
and this is what i was saying to you
earlier about depends on who what
professionals because it's not all
because i had some professional social
workers that gave me good advice but one
even when she was telling me she said to
me oh don't worry about it
don't worry about ignore that like
ignore it you wouldn't say that but
again it's because
you know sometimes it's even
subconscious because i guess a lot of
women have gone through a lot of things
it's not normal for them to come and
hear a man speak about things like this
because men don't come forward the only
reason i am comfortable because it
regarded my daughter if it wasn't that
you know you would walk away because
that wouldn't issue but when your child
is being used as a porn that's when it's
an issue
is that also part of the the abuse that
you think that men that men suffer from
like when women use children against how
i said yeah i think that's one of the
key factors and with children involved
you can have a big impact on a man's
emotions and it affects his mental
health his physical health the way he
perceives himself in the world
so
for him no sorry guys
for him um i think when
you're using his children as a porn
it
you know
he's in a position where he has to
choose between himself and his children
and a lot of people don't understand
that so
yeah just okay so with my ex-partner
i've completely cut contact
simply because
when everything happened you've attacked
me in front of my kids and then you ran
away
fine
case happened all of that i've given you
options was that recorded
what with the yes yes
in front of your children that was what
was recorded it wasn't visually recorded
it was already said to him so many times
get out of my house or i'm going to call
the police i said it about three times
and on the third time
i ran out of the house i called the
police he had me in a headlock in front
of the kids he was hitting me in front
of them and usually what was frustrating
was he wouldn't do that in front of them
he would do it in the bedroom
and then when they come towards the
bedroom it's like oh look look what your
mom's doing but then in this instant
because it was over money
it was like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
gonna do it in front of my kids whether
they're there or not so when i did call
them
and i gave them everything when they
gave him nfa and whatever it was it was
as if like
he he taunted me for about two years he
taunted me sat outside my house watching
me i reported all of these things and
they literally said there's not enough
evidence
so even with the recording you could
hear he's hitting me you could hear he
like it wasn't
i don't understand why someone would
make that up with their children in
their presence my son still remembers
this the thing is the thing is you say
that why would somebody make that up but
it's the same thing as why would amber
heard make it up fair enough do you know
what i'm saying it's like we don't i
think people in this society
um there's a lot of people with i don't
know undiagnosed mental issues do you
know what i mean and so when people
people put themselves in positions that
they shouldn't be in because that's what
i wouldn't do it well you're not them
did you get what i'm saying like because
they have a totally different actually
gonna say i was gonna say what she was
saying about um how men feel when the
children are used so he would turn
around and say to people that i'm using
the children against him
and i'm stopping him from seeing the
children i've given you the option of
going to court i've given you the option
of going to mediation
i've even said come and meet me in the
holidays
in an open space in public
whereby you can see the children
obviously he didn't know but i had a
security guard come in
simply for my own safety he still would
not agree to it but he wanted me to come
and meet him
to argue to fight
to chase on the road which is ridiculous
but he wouldn't actually come to see the
children so when people say like oh
you're using the children as a pawn it's
confusing to me because i'm giving you
all the options there
but i don't know but that's the thing is
sorry go on you know one second one
second i don't think that um they're
talking about cases where like the guy
won't see the kids and is using like the
like i think that's like your case but
when we're talking about people using
kids as pawns what we're talking about
is
cases where the mom won't let the dad
see the kids and that the dad has to go
to court spends thousands of dollars on
a lawyer begging to see the children he
will say that i'm not letting him see
that right
but you're making it very personal yeah
but no no no not not personal but i'm
saying in the sense of like there are
some men
that will talk the talk and not do what
they're supposed to do to me
i mean yeah yeah i mean yeah no i agree
like they're they're like
like they're guys that do that but what
i'm talking about is the guys that like
their guys that go to court spend
thousands of dollars and spend years
trying to fight for their kids in court
and just one day give up because
they're dead broke they've been fighting
for for like four years guys that commit
suicide over this